i'm not a very good bowler i don't i
don't bowl often
are you a good bowler icelandic noob
i think the highest score is maybe
something just under 150 for me
uh no i haven't given any consideration
to the doing a chessable course
230 is your best
that smokes my score
all right the c pawn is ready to rumble
all right let's go here i don't wanna
oh
trying to
trying to enter my house well you're you
are there
you haven't
it isn't to try you're already there man
i don't i don't plan
to take the night with the bishop my big
plan
oh let's go here i don't want to see any
of this my big plan is really to keep
this open
so here we are
that's my big plan
yeah
i um
i've played this position mostly with
white
this uh this configuration
so if i play here
now let's just go here i'm castling by
hand
so i have to be careful right if this
knight isn't around
there could be some serious problemos
but uh this guy's stable
this i may want to back up
uh yeah let's just make a quick move
i'm keeping pressure on d4 which makes
at least white think a bit more about
this advanced
um
should i hop in
let me give it a chop
yeah let me give it a chop
now let's go here
right now
to be careful because there's a this
idea soon
and this knight helps fend off that
so
okay let's chop
and then mask this
so this night is definitely there
they've taken away from the center
though i have a really nice night
and this guy could uh be captured soon i
could have you know what i should have
done
i should have maybe captured here first
yeah
okay am i not winning a pawn though
let's see
not quite
okay that move
let's defend now i couldn't i couldn't
take twice here but now maybe i can
because this
this is blocked i just wanted some extra
security over this bishop here
um
let me back up
with the idea to put it on this this
square one day
okay
um it's getting a little scary i must
say
let's start with
let's go with this i'm um
i'm basically welcome to the
exchange sacrifice
hopefully
okay
didn't see that one
my queen is stuck by the
way these two guys kill my queen but uh
this guy could come to the rescue
this is my lone defender
well
you could take either exchange i guess
which which minor piece do you want to
give up both of them are
entrenched
is that the right word
i don't know
all right my queen needs to she needs
some freedom
can
all right let's go with this actually
whoa whoa whoa whoa
i don't want to see that someday
i have to be a little careful
i have a fork here
maybe here one day
that's looking especially
appealing get rid of okay they're doing
that
oh
man
i didn't see that one
i'm in trouble
i'm in big trouble
very nice
very nice
i'm lost
oh that one i thought i'd take with the
pawn and then some kind of deflection
might put me in a pin
oh the check first
time
not easy
wow
oh
time time time is all i had they broke
my position down really well there how
did my queen end up in the corner that
was probably stupid to play to a7
that's my first thought
that's my
it's my post game analysis
that was probably stupid to play king
queen ace a7
immediately drawn to that decision after
that
what should have been a loss
huh
all right
c4
c4 would have been better
i think so if i uh i had to pick right
away that feels
much more natural
the idea to maintain pressure on i
should have considered maybe chopping on
b7 the idea to try and maintain
pressure on
d4 didn't really work out so well
all righty
all right i guess we go with simple
stuff
simple stuff
bishop here is a losing move because my
queen is an unreliable defender although
i would have that all right let's go
here now
to be careful i recently
uh ended up in a
fork
some kind of night move
now let's go with the queen it feels
more natural let's be let's maybe be a
bit more
let's be smarter with my queen moves how
about all right let's recapture with the
queen
play within this structure we both need
flight squares
uh it feels with that last move there
they have given up
opponent has given up on playing e5 but
they
still have a
c5 in mind
all right that knight's in my house
let's put some pressure on him
could support him but then this is a
hole let's jump right in it and then get
ready to kick the knight two good things
are accomplished with that one move
i don't want this guy hanging around too
long in my house all right
i can maybe tolerate the night i don't
know if i even want to
flush the night away
queen c5
let's go with this one
minority attack i thought they might
play that it's off for the queen
exchange
that's maybe a bad decision
okay
no i can't go there all right i want to
still play within the structure so i
have an active rook
let's get this guy
in the ball game
and now
i don't want to trade rocks
[Music]
well you know what i'm going to do it
like this i'm going to prepare to glue
this rook in with my flank palm
towards the center
all right
when it's playing this well
uh
not so sure about that move
okay going here i wanna i wanna break
stuff up over here
let's do it
i'm going to be able to work with this
palm and maybe get some activity if i
could track this guy down this this guy
is only three steps away so
there's also this to activate okay now i
should be
i should be able to uh
this one or this one
both as a pawn sacrifice i'll go with
the
i've got this one i guess
isn't this a one king and pun ending if
we trade rooks
not a hundred percent on that but
that pawn is pinned so there is no
capture now
yeah they i have two connected patterns
i'm going to start with this one because
i don't want this guy creeping over so
easily this i have that
oh
they're kind of out of moves
now
let's start with this
oh this and then here
not uh
not e6
give the check
here
could take here
so it should be a one king and pawn
ending
oh i have to do this
once again
not going to be easy
all right
where's my time
oh where's my time going doing too much
talking
huh i don't know
ebomb's world thank you for the tier one
resub 84 months 84 total
thank you again man
seven years for you man eigen critic
thank you for the tier one resub
59 months you had thank you jerry all
right my opponent's doing a berserk
let's let's do berserk back
play it try and play it
fast
bullet okay
let's try something uh
different
so i have a file you have a file
how about that
thinking too much
let's play in the center
oh
um
all right i'll take him
i guess bishop b5
happening soon queen e7 is
nearby
i don't know if i should have done it
like that
i'm i'm on b4
do you want a castle when my rook is
here
i'll grab the pawn
pawn grabber
let's camp out here
or maybe flush this night away
flush him away
just flush them away i have a bishop
check
this i might grab at some point but
i'm gonna
i don't know
bishop pin
let's just go here
let's return
uh
yeah
34 seconds
now there's rook takes pawn or is there
oh
that's a slick move
it's going to come down to rat race
you just watch
careful now we got pins
target on e3
i could come back to block the check
it's castle don't mouse slip
i'm on the rook
i see ya oh
all right
king moves are unnecessary i don't know
why i'm moving my king
rook is defended
okay
sam jrow thank you for the prime sub
thank you thank you
koboko
all right
i'll accept oh it looks
as if it's a gamba it's not a gambit
i normally don't capture
let's rip the pieces out
see what happens
i'll go here
let's try queenside castle
maybe have some fun with the g-pawn
all right
declining my gambit
let's see if they bite
the old fishing pole
different angle let's let's point
towards the king
this guy is not around to help defend
the
light
squares knight here could be a move
i really feel like i should be capturing
here
we had a lot of stuff
h7
jumping in here
first g5 and then this
all right this feels like
well if i go here there's knight g4
let me take here first the force is the
knight to take
yeah what am i talking about
that and then this
now
the knight moves we got me
these guys these ended up turn out to
oh they're not helping in defending the
king side so
ended up
being a waste i guess
all right
so we have this thematic
two three four
checkmate
running mate right here
and if this we have this familiar
sequence check discover check
and made on f7
okay
warship
you're hearing sounds in your head when
you log into
the twitch stream is that right
uh how do i feel about the scandy i'm a
fan of it
i like the the structure it's a very
kero con like and i'm a fan of the caro
khan
there's a small time waste in you know
having to recapture with the queen
but you know you can't have it all
playing as black
uh one one benefit is that you're not
really
when you meet e4 with d5 you're you
don't really ever have to deal with a
white pawn arriving on e5
and
we know how dangerous that could be if
you've tracked
if you have tracked
the uh
alpha zero games if i could spit it out
and let's castle
um
yeah let's go here
all right
so what do we have here this is a
a reverse dragon
i guess that's what we have
that i think the knight
this this is helpful to my rook
i think the the correct way is you drop
the knight into here
let's get out of the pin
because i have to get rid of it anyhow
and then the rook is improved and my
rook is not improved
and this rook is improved it's a lot of
that's that's a turning point all right
this square is given up i'll hop right
in
oh i'm getting this pawn no no i'm not
the queen is there to defend
it feels like there might be some well
now that this knight is moved let's get
this guy contributing
all right um let's play with this guy
okay how do i want to take
here this opens up the rook some
i'll take it away
i'll take in this in this way
but i really do like having these three
pawns at the same time
how to chop
i'll go with this one i i like that this
pawn is somewhat backward
i still have this move in mind
which should be
i'm hoping it's disruptive and at least
i don't have to think so much about a
quick
entry by the rook
also paves the way for maybe queen c6 my
knight is covering this one
i think i want to start with this uh the
rook half open file but it's biting on a
rock
this rook was not playing also this move
i could have
been much more sneaky with this move
threatens the pawn and a check that
would have been better than the rook
move
all right still though let's uh
let's get the flight square in before
maybe allowing white to go into pac-man
mode all right now no i definitely want
to
break things open because this is a
this is a weakening move
so now these moves come to mind or
you know with
some queen sneaking in maybe the night
jump here it's a lot of really nice
tactical
tactical moves nearby so i think
rook takes pawn i want to play
or
hmm
maybe let's start with
after this here okay so now this is a
little bit weakened so now i want to
take in this way
that weakened the f2 square so now i
could enter here
yeah let's get this check in
and then probably this next
in reply to almost everything queen here
i have checks there
so this this this
that's me
i think i jump in now
i have two defenders i only need one
defender of this and i have two of them
can't knock out both
with the next move so
made on g2
okay i think again looking back knight
c5 is going to be better than capturing
the bishop
and then it would start to feel much
more pressure i think
on the c file
all right we got french
i'll go straight into it
winoir
nope
okay
some pressure early on on d4 that's an
unusual move
i haven't seen that so much
let's start with that
clean there
[Music]
paving the way for b5 now
gauss
let me offer a queen exchange
i'll go here
still with an eye on that d4 square
i'm prepared to take with my king
i thought about this maneuver as well
with the id eventually fending off a
knight that may may try to sneak in here
we could have this soon
um how am i recapturing okay that one
first
i i'm kind of
prepared to give up my light square
bishop
kind of
i i like the grip that i have over d4
how to move forward from here i'm not
sure
on my end and black sand bishop e7 seems
sensible
bishop d7 as well where else was that
guy gonna go
uh
yeah
okay i'm gonna make uh
go with um
i don't know
this isn't i'm not quite sure what to do
move
it seems somewhat useful
grabbing some space i'm not seeing a way
to make great progress with my pieces
so playing with my pawns there's no
great clarity with the files i'm not
sure where the the rooks will be
productive so
all right and that one
this square you know maybe maybe i don't
like that move
my move anymore
all right
i guess here
cuts out maybe any night before move
not sure
i'm uh
i'm just unsure if the knight goes here
i guess then i chop and then try and
hunt the pawn
um
this square
yeah i'd probably just take the knight
straight away instead of trying to work
around it
okay do i ask this knight a question
let me try and uh
yeah let's see what the knight does
might want to hop around
i don't know
this controls the knight a little bit
if knight takes bishop okay that one
that one
you know take
opposite colored bishops i think coming
up
chop here chop here bishop there
bishop here i'll have a strong bishop
i'm not sure how this one's gonna go
yep
okay so not even taking the knight but i
think after this you
going to have to
i could have considered being a pawn
grabber
oh i get this guy though
i forget that i was on that maybe
i think they did
that's a big pawn
all right some security here
this pawn break may come about
how can i move forward
here i'm gonna go with this one in this
you take the pawn i get this guy back
i don't know if this is such a great
idea i am opposite the king i have a
time edge
not mind at all having my king on e4
do not mind this exchange
let's follow through
okay that one i still have this
i feel like i might have some checkmate
it's a lot of uh stuff
here now
and i don't have yeah i do have to take
back i was thinking i could do this the
bishop's on that
all right
probably want to have this open up a
little bit
um
or do i
i'll go with the you take me approach
all right i have a check should i check
first
think about the bishop
very good piece
all right um
let me get one rook off and get to a
file
i guess
we're we're entering all right
tight game
huh felt like it was going to be equal
if uh
they swiped my knight on g5 opposite
color bishops
i have some space but i don't know if
it's really
perceived as an advantage there
okay
let's begin with knight f3
all right how about d4
lucas lewin thank you for the tier one
sub
all right so
i am
prepared to
play a game but
they wanted to
hunt the pawn all right no was it
did i already play against this guy oh
right
can i not take all right let's just do
this again
this was my first round opponent
yeah so i really uh i really lucked out
our game
or did i
all right let's try this one
i don't want to see e5 i got a lot of
supporters
i could support it but that's not
without
some weakness can i take advantage of
that i don't know
let's get this one first
okay
open file
half open file
so if b6 let's go back b6
this there's that and i lose the pawn
all right
centralize
the other knight's going to arrive on d5
bishop
there prepare to offset it queen here
bishop f3
okay i don't have to react to that
let's start with this one
you take my knight i take your bishop
you take my bishop i take your bishop
maybe this wasn't the
the greatest
decision
all right we're going for that
i keep the structure as is
clean
there
makes sense
defend like this
f2
flight square
maybe
i don't like that my rooks are not
protected
is there a trick
might be a
trick some night move this was silly why
not get the coordination right away
knight f6
got the forward moves by the night
covered
there
let's give this check
and then
here
got to go faster
night there
definitely dangerous
here i have that
i want to get rid that night
what a guy
what a pest
what a guy that night
where you going
what am i even doing
i should have swiped that night
oh
tell you what let's get rid of this
knight
i've gained a little bit having this uh
pawn restricting these two
i could go here i feel it's a little
awkward looking but i have this
yeah they have that though
maybe this at some point
it's probably a wrong move
what i just did there
no time to think
all right let's get this in here
this is the new my second rank here
let me attack the pawn from the rank the
winning method is this and then here and
then here
okay tight game again against that guy
mickey hello
good evening to you
how's it going slim
fog warning thank you for the tier one
resub 50 months
now you beast
you did chest palms bora skrachev is
fantastic i haven't played him in 3
check
but
i've taken
plenty of beatings and regular chess
from him
i have viewed a lot of his games
back in the old icc days
loved watching his games
one of one of his accounts
i believe
okay i've already uh
messed this up
a little uncomfortable
i'm gonna play this where i give up this
pawn
i don't know these checks and if i try
this it feels way too loose
shouldn't be the end of the world
because this guy's backward
let's go
let's go
queenside
[Music]
it's just ready to hang a piece there
in here i think this
no no that's not true
that's not true
take with the fearless one
okay that
top around
do i have something here maybe there
okay i have a
i have a scary night do i not
scary night
when some material
or
go caveman
go for
just a quick mate
is it wait a second shouldn't i be
seeing this as that that queen's kind of
close to dead
the queen is kind of close to dead
right
and she almost she is gonna be dead now
right
with this one
and then here
some counter attack against my queen
isn't really working
knight here my bishop could fall back i
think best is this now
let me take the queen and i think i
immediately give this right back i don't
want this bishop cutting into my
king's house so now maybe
we're ready for this
you got pawn hunting
i want one rook off so this is my big
bad plan
at the same time
i do not want to see this kind of clamp
down on the f6 square
i thought about this before moving my
rook but this is this should be more to
the point
neutralize the rook because if you get
one rook off then the coordination
becomes much much more
difficult for white
so even if i have to retreat on
recapture this is the main
main thing welcome that one rook
exchange
okay
let's chop first
like a chop again with the queen
i'm still there defending the rook
is there some fancy in-betweener
queen takes pawn check
i don't think so
all right so let's let's take this rook
queen g7
or queen queen g2
um
and do it like this win the uh
f4 pawn
and i guess start running
not easy to coordinate
and then as soon as there's an
unprotected
we get the get the piece
all right he resigned
only 14 to go
448 in there
uh
evan0465 thank you for the tier one
resub 37 months
yeah it's so glad to catch a stream hope
you're doing well i'm i'm doing good
thank you
uh very low sodium thank you for gifting
five sub uh five subs
appreciate it man
be cruet
all right let's go with a
let's go with d6
maybe a king's indian defense
or you know what let's let's go with
this
some old indian action
e5
e5 all i want
is to establish a pawn on e5
um
i've seen these uh
wild man
moves
crazy g4
g4 g5 all right that's a
a modest deployment for the light square
bishop it's more commonly posted on c4
so i'm staying flexible with this move i
may want to
go like this okay so they're going
they have gone queen side
i'm gonna go with this baby step
approach
this straight away i think there's this
and it's
there's an issue with defending b5 so
this and then this is my plan let's see
if white ever gives up uh
if white ever initiates this exchange if
this advance
um
[Music]
what am i going to do maybe capture
straight away our castles okay we have
it on board
chop right now
oh you know what i could have also
considered this move which hunts the
dark square bishop
i'll go with the chop let's see how they
uh
how they react first
i don't have time to take the e pawn if
knight takes they're on my queen
so this is this could turn out to be a
hole
because of this decision
but
this guy's a long way would be a long
ways away okay well they're
clogging it up there
so we have a majority
four versus three on the king side now
uh i don't think i'm going to be
castling queenside so
let's go here
no i want to be careful about this f5
move
to try and get this in with first h6 it
seems too uh
too long-winded all right i'm gonna go
with this
this is a this is a square now
maybe the knight even jumps around i
could have went here straight away but
i don't know this kind of is appealing
knight on g4
bishop bishop here i get that f2 pawn
i'm developing with my last move okay
um
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in here
i'm okay with that
and
take the bishop no i don't want to see
the file open up so i'm going to have to
wait
so this pawn has some depth they don't
have an open file though and
if i get this guy and this is unopposed
this guy should uh
find it convenient to
hunt
the dark square bishop
oh i'm going to take straight away
and i think i want to play with this one
why though
why are you going to do that
no and
maybe this
yeah i think i want to get rid of their
knight
and then uh this this stuff
where i stay strong on the light squares
i can afford to give up the my light
square bishop
i'll find good coordination with my dark
square bishop in structure
and i'm developing
ready for an attack against c2 okay so
that exchange
i guess i'll go for it
let's generate a threat
maybe offer a queen exchange
[Music]
yeah let's go here
all the time
okay
so this this is seen now with the
queen's off i see it more as a
as a what a liability
now let's take and then bishop g5
right there i have that pawn
okay so i could i could get this pawn
do i want it though
gonna make a an oddball move
oh well i just
killed all my time there
oh there's this
seventh rank is weakened oh
i'm missing moves now
that uh
this last handful of moves did not go so
well
opponent is flying
oh
i spent ways too much time on that one
move
oh crazy
okay let's go with e4 let's turn this
one
i'm not we're gonna
take a detour from the the french
turn into a king's indian attack
all right
they can allow me to play e5 now they're
they've they're they're fighting against
that
let's
try to insist on it okay they're still
saying no
you will not play that so easily
uh i don't know if this is right
i'm going to try it though i think i
want to take with the piece
okay
i think i want that one
i get wait they don't have control over
this anymore
that wins the bishop
huh he's stuck
i almost missed that
take with no we're gonna take with the
the pawn
no rush yeah taking this guy
simply oh they really they resigned
oh that was the first well he was right
there with my score
all right we're probably gonna get one
more game in
try e4 again
now let's try it again
so let's see
my opponents re
reply in this in this game are they
gonna try and fend off okay they're
going with the fianchetto
let's get these
okay so that's a big decision
uh how do i want to approach this
i guess i ignore it
let me let me play with this i'm
stopping d5 and i'm paving the way for
f4
let's race with this pawn see what
happens okay chop
chop and
chop probably have to play f5
okay i get f5 in
okay
that
is this not
super duper weakening to their king side
it definitely is super duper weakening
do i want to take with the pawn
[Music]
or develop my queen
this with this here and here
probably
i probably take
the pawn
i think this guy wants this square
okay
let me go here straight away
now maybe i should have played the queen
out first
all right let's get here this is more
defensive than anything
yeah i'm defending against queen h4 with
this
so it is it's aggressive yeah it's
aggressive and defensive
oh now this is maybe upon um
kind of all right with giving up
i may want to flick in c3 but i'll be
looking for something more
forceful if i can
um maybe it is
perfectly fine
making this defensive move though
offer a queen exchange huh
okay
i'll i'll be okay with that i think
and let's try this
i want i want these two this is the
i'm kind of
viewing this bishop as the glue
to black's position
no bishop and
these guys fall
one of the two i think fall
all right so now you have to take with
okay this could be a runner soon
do i even want to run though
let's run
it's not easy to remove this rook like
if you want to do this and then here
this knight isn't protected
all right i might be winning something
soon
bishop here i have that similar to
previous game
so rook here but if rook here i have
this and then here i think i'm i think
i'm winning
some bishop move i have a four
this is a one dangerous piece right here
g5
the king is on an open file
okay that one
pieces are sliding in there should be
another
me up a full rook now
all right they resigned
final game coming up
let's try
carrollcon
advanced
okay
to make some defensive moves
hmm
i'm afraid of something i just can't
voice it just yet i'm not quite sure
uh
all right let me try this
i was afraid of some
quick f4 f5
if i play this this was going to be
super vulnerable it's afraid of
my center collapsing i guess in short
all right so
i have this square that's what i'm
focused on now
and i think i'm going to play without c5
i want to remain
solid on on this point
my queen can maybe come out
okay
it might be this i might want to jump in
here
that's too long-winded
we're going to find out
so if this knight isn't around like if
these three there are these two
these three
if they're if they're all exchanged then
this pawn is likely to fall
pawn takes pawn i'm probably taking at
the pawn i don't think i want to see the
niko here
could run into some problems along the c
file
i may castle queenside
there's this maybe knight c5 and then
here okay forget about it my knight is
gonzo
okay take with this
okay clean there
tell you what let's get castled this way
you're gonna take that guy
might be up for grabs
knows
wow so greedy man so greedy you weren't
supposed to do that
i'll babysit this pawn remote for the
moment
i'm down two ponds
are the two extras though doubled and
isolated
and passed but we'll see if they could
get running and scare me
let's get my king here first of all
don't want to see that pawn
can't
can't allow that
maybe this was better
okay let's go here
with what exactly in mind i'm not sure
trying to trap the queen
no no it's a secure square
this and then here
nice to go here and have the queen
pinned right away but
still a lot
um
let's go here
pick up this pawn
how about this plan that seems like a
good spot secures my king really well on
this square
good defender and
i think it turns out to be a number one
piece
dark square bishop on b6
i'm not really seeing a great way for
white to improve position opposite my
king but not seeing any tricks
and i want to be careful about uh
about what
still go here i might have to work
around a night on that square
get out of any checks
the queen here maybe i do this
get that knight out
and then hunt this pawn
yeah they're in a complete prevent here
with the rooks
only have three seconds
all right can i find a
what's the best move here
i'm not sure what the best move is
let's just be ultra
ultra safe
exchange some stuff
all right they're down on time at the
end of the day
okay got a 12 games played only 11
counter for the tournament
been a while
an hourly super blitz arena
495 in there
there's your top ten
let's see who else
your top
100
all right there we go
been a while
good games
to all some close games in there
you